I feel like John Ambrose did not get the
ending that he deserves how did you feel
about that ending you know I think that
a lot of people would agree he found
himself in the situation like
unwillingly a geeky there's history
there Ryan liked it
John n versus large means first love it
was the first letter that she ever wrote
it was her first like a really big crush
that she didn't know what to do with
they didn't see each other I mean like
go into another school at that age is
pretty much like moving across the world
like there's no other you're
disconnected and so for them to find
themselves back in the same place
coincidentally especially were timing
his concern cuz it's all about timing
that's what really that's what this film
is all about like it's it's it's it's a
lesson in like timing is not always in
our control and that's okay Jordan is
personally more team Peter for Laura
Jean and like I really yeah I think like
for high school college
however like as somebody who's not 17
who's like a little bit older than that
and about to get married like John M
Bruce is the marrying type like he's the
guy that you're like hi thanks John
embers is daddy you know I'm sad and I
think that he's secure in that you know
what I'm saying like he he didn't he's
not a homewrecker he didn't know about
like the relay he didn't know what was
going on
found himself in this weird position and
then kind of like had his wildest dreams
come true at the end of the film and
that's where I think that that's where
everyone's hearts break is just like oh
he didn't deserve do you think there
should have been a little more than just
the the kiss in the run
was that the right way yeah honestly
it's like he got it they kissed he
looked at like he is socially aware and
emotionally intelligent enough to go I
know what it is and it's okay so you
weren't personally bummed
are you lying of us you know I'm saying
I gonna be lying because I love John
Ambrose he's such a sweetheart
he's like the B's the perfect guy you
know and like did no wrong and have pure
intentions the whole time so how can
anybody dislike him omit I feel like
everybody wants to root for him for that
reason you know I really thought you did
such a great job yes
you really were so charming thank you I
appreciate that do we think there's room
for him in the third movie possibly I
mean want to see I did you film for it
have you read any scripts the film has
happened who are you in it I cannot
confirm nor deny happened so we'll have
to see is there room for him in your
opinion like would you like to see him
in the third movie I think that the
filming for the third film has already
taken place and I Jordan Fisher cannot
confirm nor deny John Ambrose's
involvement
that's fair that's a very diplomatic
answer how's wedding planning going
thank you it's going very well
she's around here somewhere and she's
like this stunning blonde with the red
dress on so whenever you see that it's
going really well I mean like you know
we're getting married in Hawaii it's in
July it's a whole bunch of stuff
happening between now and then we're
like my brain is kind of all over the
place so she and like my PR team they've
been doing such a beautiful job of kind
of constructing things but bring me
something like once every two weeks and
be like hey like yes no and I'd be like
sure here we go
you know but they're doing a beautiful
job by kind of putting the thing
together and I'm just thrilled that it's
in my happy place that's earlier are you
gonna sing at the wedding we'll see well
if someone answers tonight you know
there's some things you gotta like keep
it to keep on the rat baby you gotta
like you know kind of hold on to your
cards a little bit down baby come on you
know you gotta play the piano or the
guitar you do both anything I do I do
all of those things must really be a
Jordan Fisher wedding without like a
little samba Lindsay comes out with a
little song
we'll have to see it's gonna be like a
big fat family vacation somewhere that's
something we're mostly excited about you
know we grew up in Alabama together like
that's it we met we were nine and
thirteen years old so we have like and
I've been in LA for 13 years so she has
so much connection in Alabama still
where I have some extended family la is
very much home for me and I kind of have
home in New York as well so like it just
made sense for us to do a destination do
a dinner in Alabama do a dinner in LA to
a dinner in New York but like actually
have the ceremony and the celebration
itself somewhere far away you know are
the are the co-stars invited there's
some are we gonna see Noah and Lana
dancing on the dance floor at the
wedding keeping things very very private
do you notice and you're gonna see like
it's gonna be a whole big thing
afterwards but like we're private people
and like to keep you know certain things
to ourselves and for us because like so
much of my life is outward there's so
many things in my life that I like to
like you know keep sacred you know
Valentine's Day what are we doing well
working on tier of enhancing on Broadway
right now so I'm literally deal by the
way literally playing oven that night
just sobbing and crying and singing my
ass up on stage bleep my bad but uh I
mean that's that's gonna be Valentine's
Day it's oh I honestly probably just
will probably get up in the morning
she'll have work that day will probably
like have a little breakfast and then
she'll go do her work I'll stream on
Twitch I'll go do the show
we'll probably like half the night with
an episode of cheer and a glass of wine
I'm like obsessed he's interviewed we
did a sit-down with them
Gabby Butler came to see Devin handsome
the day after I started watching the
show and one of our PR people came back
after the show and I'm all like puffy
and gross and like getting dressed and
stuff to go out to the stage door and
she's like hey Gabby Butler from Chiara
said what she's like she is in the green
room like what we call it the blue room
she's like she said moving like wants to
meet you I was like okay like she's a
beast she's an animal she's so great and
so sweet
[Music]